[Music]
today I'm going to be talking about you
know the challenges and opportunities to
attain reproducibility in data science
right and why is this important this is
important because data has really
transformed our society in many
different ways if we look at science
every scientific domain has moved toward
data-driven exploration right and we'll
get into what Jim Gray termed as a
fourth paradigm where we went from
hypothesis testing to hypothesis
generation to data exploration companies
are capitalizing on data and many
companies their main business actually
comes from the data they collect and
process right so it's not surprising
that data has been touted as the new oil
right and last but not least government
is increasingly using data to become
more efficient to inform policies and
the decisions that comes with these
policies and all of these actually have
been enabled by this perfect storm where
we have computing industry we have
storage registry and we have lots and
lots of data now available to everyday
everybody right data has been
democratized I argue that the main
problem we have now is that the
bottleneck of actually leveraging these
data and computing actually lies with
people and the reason for that is yes we
have lots of data that's great but they
come from many different sources and
they have different levels of
reliability to get insights from data we
need to assemble complex computational
processes and these are hard to build
you need to have knowledge of algorithms
machine learning statistics
visualization data integration data
cleaning etc right and this problem is
compounded by the fact that you know as
you explore data this is an inherently
iterative process where you get data you
perform some computation you look at the
results you understand try to understand
what's going on and from that
understanding you go ahead and you
change your computational pipeline build
other data products and so when you keep
doing this in an iterative fashion right
like for example you get some data you
need to build a model you first have to
clean the data you cluster the data to
get a sense of what the data looks like
you create a visualization you find
issues you clean the data again you
create your initial model the
performance is not that great you go
ahead
you know transforming your data you've
even more visualizing refining your
model oh you got a good result 92% then
you rerun your model you get a point 75%
and behind your backup he knows to you
your system administrator updated
scikit-learn right so now you get a
result you don't know if you use the
right version of the data from all the
different versions that you have clean
or if it was updated the update to
scikit-learn that actually impacted your
results right so this illustrates one
big issue that we have now which is you
know these exploratory data-driven
exploration processes they require lots
of steps iterative steps and after you
go through many of these steps you know
it's very easy to get lost and not
remember exactly how you got there
you've got great result
how did you get there things can break
even behind your back with libraries
with different versions of files that
people changing data behind your back
right and in the end the results you end
up with can be very hard to understand
interpret and Trust right and then when
you go from the store choose path from
data to knowledge and eventually to
decisions you need to trust it because
incorrect conclusions based on this kind
of analysis can lead to bad decisions
right and what I claim is that in order
to address these challenges you need to
be able to systematically capture
provenance for everything that you do
with your data and all the computation
is
you follow so what is provenance this is
a term that is widely used in art in
archaeology it's the source of origin
and an object it's a history of pedigree
and the record of the ultimate
derivation of an item through various
owners right when you move to
computations computational provenance
can actually be thought of as a causal
recraft that models all the processes
and data dependencies and I'm gonna give
you an example right and these are
actually key ingredients for one to
obtain transparency and reproducibility
of your computational results right so
if you look at that crazy multiple step
example that I gave you this is a more
accurate depiction of what actually
happened you start with some data you
clean the data you carry a new version
of the clean data you do a clustering
and to generate a new data product which
is what you end up visualizing right but
then the first the version one of the
data you clean it again you create a
different version now you create a
different model which is actually
another artifact right so here what you
can see is that you know this process
can be complex and has lots of different
dependencies you have these data
dependencies right like for example the
final model that I created depends on
everything that happened beforehand
right in particular there are
dependencies on other data sets the
input data the clean data the clean data
the second time around and you also have
sorry process dependencies right in
order to run the model you first must
clean the data in this example multiple
times or if you're trying to visualize a
particular data it has to be clean
before right so provenance in the
computational sense is a causality graph
and what are the benefits of having this
graph one is that you can interpret and
reproduce the results and this is really
important today as I said when you make
decisions based on data you can
understand
the the whole experiment and the chain
of reasoning that was followed to
produce a particular result you because
you have the whole trail you can also
verify whether you know whoever did the
experiment follow the acceptable
procedures you can identify inputs to an
experiment where they came from and if
you find out the particle data set is
bad right you know what with derived
results you can actually invalidate very
important you can also rerun and
reproduce the results by you know we
executing the steps and you can do that
also by varying other parameters so that
you can obtain trust right and see if
what you have is actually robust right
this also helps you debug your results
if you find a problem can you figure out
whether that was a scikit-learn
or it was a wrong data version that you
use to run your model and last but not
least this is really key if you actually
want not only to share but also reuse
the work that you've done in the past
right so when you look at the provenance
in science in general like if you have
biological experiments or social
experiments it can be really hard to
replicate a particular study right but
when we ever have computations they are
actually carried out in a controlled
environment so in theory it's actually
possible and should be not too hard to
systematically capture what happens in a
computational environment right but then
the question that you have to ask is
what should you capture and the answer
here depends on what you use the
provenance for right in some cases you
just want to document the computational
process have maybe a textual description
of what you went through in some other
instances you want to be able to rerun
what you've ran before or even share
that so that others can run in different
environments and of course you may want
to be able to extend modify and
you know assess the reliability of the
results right so one question for you is
why do we talk about that all of this if
you know yes we already write programs
we can use a jupiter notebook and thus
you know captures detailed description
of your analysis right so here I have an
analysis that I did on New York City a
taxi data and I have my whole notebook
right
is this enough to get reproducibility
right so what I could do is a go to my
browser and if I can't find it oh okay
maybe I can I have it here right it's
already here and this is a you know I I
can try to run it again fine I'm gonna
read my taxi data and boom it doesn't
work anymore because I have a new laptop
and the data is not in the path that I
had specified for my notebook right so
there are some little details we need to
worry about even when we use tools like
Jupiter that are supposed to enable you
to attain reproducibility right and just
to give you an idea recently together
with collaborators and the student we
analyzed almost 1.5 million notebooks
that we collected from github and out of
these we were able to extract a little
bit over a million that are valid and
here valid means that they have a
defined Python version and an execution
order and the results you know to me
were surprising because only 25% of this
one million actually executed without
errors and only 4.5 7% produced the same
results as the original notebook right
and you know in the paper we described a
number of problems that
you know these notebooks have and one is
that people don't specify the actual
versions of libraries they use in their
notebooks like in my taxi analysis
lots of people use hard-coded paths
there's also a problem with outer order
cells right that if you have we executed
you're gonna get you know incorrect
state and you have also decision with
hidden states right so even in a tool
that is supposed to help people work in
a reproducible way you can have serious
problems and with Jupiter you can try to
avoid these by following a set of best
practices like using relative paths or
external data repositories that can live
and work across different computing
environments before you commit and save
your notebook to get hub you can you
should rerun top to bottom before so
that you know that things are consistent
you should declare your dependencies and
library versions and use the clean
environment to testing appendices right
and that's as you know I'll fine and
dandy but you know if you just tween
data exploration and you're trying to
figure out you know you drive your new
hypothesis and you're trying to figure
out the next steps right although this
sounds very hard to do and often you're
left with a notebook that you've worked
for several months and how do you make
that reproducible so one alternative is
to use this tool that we developed
called reprozip and the way that
repressive works is that it has two
steps if you have a notebook or if you
have a python script or an interactive
application you can actually pack that
application in a container that has all
the necessary dependencies for their
application to run in a different
environment right so you pack and then
you can actually unpack it in different
environments windows linux mac OS and so
on so what are the advantages of using
such a tool it actually automatically
tracks all the dependencies in an
environment and we'll set them up in a
different environment so you actually
get this port
ability and allowing others to use or
even yourself to use it in a different
computational environment that deals
with all these variability that is
ubiquitous in computation environments
and it enables you to attain
reproducibly in hindsight so I will show
you with the video how this actually
works but underneath what represent does
is that it relies on P trace and as you
run your application it will
automatically check everything that gets
called all the files that are read
including put files libraries and so on
it will generate like a bill of shipping
bill right everything that was used it
will analyzes provenance and will
generate a configuration file that you
as a user can actually edit and
customize what gets backed and last but
not least it generates this package that
contains all those dependencies in the
unpacking step you can you get as the
RPC file that contains all dependencies
and it will unpack that in you know many
different ways that can impact if you
use a compatible operating system in a
directory or you can use a virtual
machines such as vagrant docker and many
other Packers and this is one poor in
point where the system is extensible you
can create an packers for different
kinds of environments so how does this
work and here's a short video that shows
how you were packing a jupiter notebook
so this is just a notebook that we use
as an example and it's for brain
analysis for brain imaging which is
actually a domain that people have been
using this too quite a lot so the way
that you practice is you simply call
reprozip as you can see there jupiter in
this case and you trace the execution so
what does this cannon do is that it's
gonna you know call jupiter will run top
to bottom and that's how that happened a
proper zipper striking out the
dependencies so it now it created a
configuration file and now it will
package all the different dependencies
so now that you have this RPC and this
was done in a Linux machine all right we
can go to a Mac and there we do repro
unzip and we are gonna be doing
unpacking on docker and that's what this
is going to be doing is gonna be
creating this docker container with all
the dependencies in them and we can then
run that docker container and we're
gonna get the exact same notebook that
we got on linux and here's the notebook
here
so unlike my notebook if I had revenues
representative rerun all the different
steps alright so we've also done jupiter
extension that you can install and
instead of calling represent you just
click on the little button on the top
right and in jupiter and it will
actually pack that for you much more
easily than when i show it with a
comment line so what can represent pack
that can repack scripts software
anything that you can call from the
command line it can pack graphical tools
interactive tools client-server
applications in fact we've been doing
recently a lot of work on packaging news
apps that jupiter node pootis has very
soon but it's done already NPI
experiments and many more and you can
see more examples in this link here so
another tool that we've developed as
this called repro server that allows you
to run any packaged experiment any
experiment patched with leprosy just
using a browser right so if you guys
have seen binder this is like a similar
idea except now that you can actually
also capture state right so the idea is
that you can just you know point your
browser to the RPC the wrappers it
package and it will create the
environment in your browser and it will
allow you also to modify parameters
input data and so on and we run that on
the fly and this whole infrastructure is
set up in a way that you can deploy it
in an Amazon or Google cloud or in your
own computational environment okay so
I'm gonna skip over this but I'd be
happy to tell you more about this during
my office hours after the talk okay so
tools like you know pre preserve or if
you document your code you document the
provenance of your experiment through
your code
it's great and it works when you know
for individual components of an analysis
right but as we've shown before an
analysis can contain several different
steps that you iteratively go through
during the expiratory process right so
and you know one of them here like maybe
cleaned a time using Jupiter maybe to
visualize I use a third-party tool maybe
I create a model using PI torch or some
other you know machine learning package
right so one challenge is you know how
do you actually capture all these
different steps that can actually happen
in different tools and in different
environments
and as I said you know because these all
happen in a computer it should be
possible to capture the whole the
details of the whole exploration process
and we've actually developed another
tool called these trails that will
automatically capture you know complex
exploration that is carried out within a
workflow system but unlike in the
previous talk that talked about
production workflows there's workflow
system here that we created is to
support data exploration and data
analysis right and the idea is that that
will automatically and transparently
capture all the steps that you follow
through so you can start with a simple
workflow that plots a histogram and you
can you know add data you can try
different visualizations like a scatter
plot for example and you keep doing that
and essentially the two keeps this
history very much like get right but for
data analysis and what we've shown is
that such a tool not only enables you to
attain reproducibility because every
node here is one state of your analysis
that you can reacts acute but it also
has many benefits that go beyond
reproducibility first and foremost that
supports reflective reasoning right we
humans have limited memory you can
remember you know five six things at a
time
and when you do these analysis that have
you know potentially hundreds of steps
it's very hard for us to remember where
we've been but by having this history
you can actually go back few steps and
you know think and reason about all the
different paths that you've actually
followed you are able to more easily and
accurately compare different results
like for example the different models
the model that remnant that have
different f measures when you look and
this is a different example where I'm
actually creating different
visualizations for the visible human I
look at these images they look slightly
different but what are the real
differences behind them and by having
this detailed provenance expiratory
provenance I can actually look at the
different workflows that generated those
images and I can see that on the left
side here in orange this visualization
is actually using isosurfaces and I have
a contour filter where the one on the
right side is using volume rendering and
I can see exactly that you know the
right one uses these three orange blocks
and in the right one
you have the blue box that replace the
orange blocks so you can see you can see
the differences visually but you can
also see the steps that the difference
in steps that led to the different
visualizations and behind those we
actually have an algebra which I don't
have time to get into but that also
enables you to compute these differences
in a very efficient way even for very
large workflows this model also allows
you to systematically explore parameter
spaces so you can check in this case for
the for this visualization you can check
different values for your isosurface and
you can see what effect it has on the
final visualization but the same
mechanism can actually be used for you
to explore different methods to do your
analysis so here used
as a surface it's contour visualize a
contour the contours of the images but I
could very easily change my analysis and
use volume rendering for all of them so
you can not only explore parameters but
you can explore different modules or
different functions and last but not
least just like the way that we used it
for collaboration this also provides
support for multiple people and big
groups to actually collaboratively
analyze data and this is an example of a
real exploration that was done with
folks that the work the orange ones are
in Utah and the blue ones are in sorry
at University of Washington they were
looking at simulations of the river the
Columbia River in Party Pacific
Northwest another thing that we showed
is that even though we use this
provenance model for a exploratory work
flow system the model is extensible it
can be used to instrument other
applications to capture similar kind of
information so we use the same
methodology to instrument Autodesk Maya
which is an interactive tool used to
build three-dimensional models in
Whitely it's widely used in a gaming
industry and movie industry so the same
kind of functionality that we had in
this trails is available in Maya we also
did that for a couple systems that are
used to do trivialization scientific
visualizations that that are used at
yogi labs and also another tool that's
using by NIH to visualize I think cell
date or something like that so just to
give you an idea here's a replay of you
know the provenance of exploration for
an artist that was building the model
for a plane right so this was all
captured while the artist was building
the model and you can replay and see
step by step what the artist did to
build that particular model okay so you
know just one final thing so I mentioned
to you that we developed this provenance
model for these trails
implemented it and built a sprat plug-in
infrastructure that enables people to
instrument other kinds of applications
and more recently we've evolved this
idea to actually capture exploratory
provenance for notebooks right so I
wanted to do it with Jupiter but the
code base was too complicated so we
ended up building our own notebook
called Vizier and essentially you can
think of easier as a data centric
notebook that keeps track not only of
everything that is executed all the
different states everything what happens
in the notebook but more importantly it
also manages the data and all the
different versions of data that are
manipulated by your notebook so and so
Westside I would need another talk to
talk about all these things but you can
you know look for more information in
this URL and again I'd also be happy to
talk to you after the talk and the last
thing I wanted to talk about is that as
I said provenance is key for one to
build trust in results but it's also a
necessary component that to enable one
provenance and reproduce spiritual able
people to debug their there Nate
analysis pipelines right so here's an
example of a simple machine learning
pipeline that you read some data you
split the training tasks you build an
estimation an estimator you compute
score and you have the final score right
and here's the provenance of different
runs that we had for this particular
pipeline using different you know
estimators as well as you know different
library versions for scikit-learn and
one interesting thing that you can see
by analyzing the provenance is that you
know there's two cases here where the
score is actually very low and the
execution fails right and you know how
do you figure out what is causing these
failures
this very low score right so the ability
to actually rerun these pipelines
enables us to automatically figure out a
set of parameters and what you vary in
these workflows so that we can
automatically detect what the causes are
right so in this case we ran our
algorithm and it actually found that the
problem here is not that it's gradient
boosting versus decision tree but it was
actually a bug that was introduced in
the psychie learn version 2.0 right
again you know we have details of this
work in a paper that was recently
presented and the Sigma deem workshop
right but again the ability the the
availability of provenance and the
ability to rerun can actually greatly
simplify the process of debugging and
building trust in the analysis results
so to conclude I hope I have convinced
you that provenance and reproducibility
are necessary for data science they
enable data scientists and data
enthusiasts such a beaut trust on their
own work and also it can help others
trust the work that you do right for a
long time people have argued that they
don't do things in a reproducible way
because it's hard we no longer have this
excuse there's lots of tools not only
the ones that I mentioned today but you
have you know virtualization you have
get you have a number of great
infrastructure nowadays that makes the
process of creating reproducible results
much easier than it used to be and
there's also simple best practice that
if you follow you can attain
reproducibility one caveat is that you
know in many in some cases full
reproducibility is not possible and that
happens when you have proprietary code
or when you have proprietary data or
when you use very special hardware that
is not widely available but even in this
case is there some way that you know at
least part of your work can be
reproducible right and that's important
to actually ensure that the part that is
possible is actually done
correctly and recently we've seen a lot
of attention to the problem of explain
ability fairness and ethics for data
science right and you know again
provenance is a key component for that
how do you explain the results that you
have how do you explain how do you prove
that you know your model or your
analysis is not bias versus gender
religion it's so on and so forth right
so this is I think a very interesting
area and there's a lot of ongoing work
ongoing research in developing
techniques that use provenance to
actually support explain ability and
better debugging for these pipelines and
finally you know I urge you all to
practice reproducibility it's good for
everybody but especially for you thank
you so much and I'd be happy to answer
questions so in in research right now
are people running any of these
processes by hand to make sure that the
results are reproducible or is this
completely like it's not a thing that
researchers really think about at the
moment so so at least in science and
there's a recent report by the National
Academies that I helped out there it's
actually a requirement anything that you
publish any it's not science if it's not
reproducible right so there is already
journals conferences when you publish a
paper it's expected that you also
provide your code your data so that
others can reproduce and a number of
these venues have already established
procedures where people will verify will
rerun and verify whether the results
actually are consistent to what is
reported in the paper
I'm sorry so there's no real study that
shows what the results are consistent
I've been helping with one conference
and often times they are consistent very
few times that happen in this particular
conference I see em Sigma that the
results were not consistent and but
sometimes there had had to be like a
back and forth with authors because
sometimes they didn't the author it
didn't provide the exact parameters and
so on to run the things right
[Music]